et c'est parti notre challenger vont
découvrir de nouvelles énigmes tirées au
sort
j'espère que Anne ne s'est pas blessé
cela restera peut-être comme le dernier
feu d'artifice dans le ciel nîmois le 14
juillet 2022 le traditionnel spectacle
pyrotechnique ravissait les yeux des
spectateurs mais cette année la mairie a
décidé de tourner la page dans trois
jours deux sandrônes offriront un show à
22h30 dans le jardin de la Fontaine on a
même pas eu le temps de s'ambiancer
là-dessus
[Musique]
la Fédération des assureurs annonce ce
matin que les émeutes qui ont suivi la
mort du jeune Naël à Nanterre il y a
deux semaines ont coûtait romain ou pour
RMC 650 millions d'euros oui et pourtant
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière la
même fédération estimait la facture à
280 millions d'euros c'est donc
finalement plus du double que ce qui
était anticipé au total la Fédération
parle de 11300 déclarations de sinistre
qui sont parvenus aux assureurs on a
entendu quoi dans certaines émeutes dans
certains quartiers quand les
sauvageons attaquaient les forces de
l'ordre des halagbar
à répétition on a entendu quoi on a
entendu quoi dans la bouche de certains
manifestants à Nanterre des représailles
des musulmans contre les forces de
l'ordre avec des appels à la haine et au
meurtre donc quand vous refaites un peu
l'histoire non je ne refais pas
l'histoire je fais j'ai énumère des
faits
[Musique]
ici on a une liberté totale de parole et
c'est pour ça c'est la force de cette
émission et c'est pour ça que c'était
mission est génial je suis pas sûr que
sur le service public on aurait la même
liberté mais voilà les deux conceptions
qui sont différentes les Grandes Gueules
font du bien la démocratie
le français les visions parfois j'ai de
gros doute je partage totalement
tu veux dire quelque chose à la télé non
tu veux dire bon tu veux dire bonjour à
quelqu'un non tu tu veux changer une loi
dans le pays non tu est-ce que tu
aimerais que les enfants et le droit de
manger autant de bonbons qu'ils veulent
[Applaudissements]
Notre-Dame la croisière a été brève
depuis
Ivry-sur-Seine en proche banlieue les
premiers éléments de charpente ont fait
route vers la cathédrale par le chemin
le plus direct nous utilisons des moyens
de transport à notre disposition
celui-ci est parfait d'abord il est
écologique la polémique Isiah prend de
l'ampleur le concert de la chanteuse
prévu jeudi soir prochain à
Marcq-en-Baroeul dans le Nord a été
annulé une enquête est également ouverte
pour provocation à commettre un crime ou
un délit après une diatribe hostile à
Emmanuel Macron qu'elle a prononcé en
concert à La Rochelle pour le festival
des Francofolies le maire a demandé des
garanties à la chanteuse moi ce que je
souhaite pas c'est qu'à La Rochelle on
tienne des discours de haine c'est
insupportable qu'elle n'est pas question
à la recherche de tenir des tels propose
pour moi aussi elle recommence pas
l'incident éclos dans Ouest-France la
chanteuse Isia réagi affirme que ses
propos ont été mal interprétés et
décontextualisé
elle affirme n'avoir à aucun moment
voulu inciter à la violence ou à la
haine Ricky Valérie colleux 22 ans est
devenu la première femme trans à devenir
Miss Pays-Bas entre les messages de
haine et les témoignages de soutien elle
a décidé de faire de sa victoire un
message d'amour love
you en France cela ne fait que deux ans
que les femmes trans mais aussi les
femmes de plus de 25 ans et les femmes
mariées ont le droit de se présenter à
Miss France l'année dernière une jeune
femme trans avait été première dauphine
de Miss Paris mais elle ne s'était pas
qualifiée pour la finale nationale cette
année c'est en Isère qu'une femme trans
de 33 ans s'est présenté sans parvenir
non plus à se qualifier car notre équipe
s'apprête à prélever des échantillons
dans des zones encore inexplorées
il me reste à déterminer le rôle de mon
ami
[Musique]
elle est l'une des 95 chinois de
l'équipe 91 hommes 4 femmes
et moi le paradis non ça on pouvait
divorcer mais uniquement s'il y avait
faute et c'était quand même un sujet
tabou avec le divorce par consentement
mutuel Valéry Giscard d'Estaing offre
une vraie avancée et voici ce qu'en
pense les premiers concernés je trouve
que c'est plus honnête que tout ce qui
pouvait être fait avant moi je trouve un
shining admissible bonne souffrance
devrait être pas se marier divorcer
quand elles veulent
[Musique]
il y a un bateau là-bas allez
cheminée rouge c'est Titanic là-bas mais
je m'en fous par là on ira après de
l'autre côté
il ne croit pas si bien dire